talk conservation rocky spoke with them
about their water smart landscapes
rebate program
here's more so i know
water conservation is so important here
in southern nevada so what are
what's the update on our water supply
and what can we do to help
well you know the colorado river which
provides 90 percent of the water for us
here in southern nevada
has been experiencing significant
drought conditions over the past
two decades and this year it's no better
in fact we're seeing very low snowpack
in the colorado rockies
and the projections for lake mead are
that lake mead is going to drop another
15 feet
this year alone so it's already dropped
130 feet it's gonna drop another 15 feet
but
as long as southern nevada keeps
conserving and keeps saving water
our community will be just fine but
we've got to stay focused on water
conservation
and really rocky the number one way that
we can conserve water here in southern
nevada on a permanent basis
is getting rid of grass and the southern
nevada water authority
has the water smarts landscapes program
it is a program where we will pay three
dollars
for every square foot of grass that that
any property owner removes
and that helps to offset the cost of
making that switch
but more importantly that saves water
and that reduces your water bill
and these kinds of projects upgrading
your grass to water smart landscaping
they pay for themselves over time so
you can make this investment you can
beautify your landscape
and you can get permanent water savings
that will reduce your water bill
great reminder and let's talk more about
the the water
smart landscapes what do they look like
what are our options water smart
landscapes are really intended
to be drip irrigated trees and shrubs
that are
in a landscape it's really anything
other than grass
because grass gets irrigated with spray
irrigation and spray irrigation delivers
gallons per minute drip irrigation which
is very
pinpointed and much more efficient uses
gallons per
hour so making the switch from spray
irrigation to drip irrigation
from grass to plants and shrubs will
save you
55 gallons per square foot
think about this a square foot of grass
requires
10 feet of water every single year just
to survive
that's that's that's the depth of a
swimming pool that has a diving board
10 feet of water for a water smart
landscape
it only uses three feet of water so it's
a significant difference between grass
and drip irrigated trees and shrubs and
your landscape will
still look great it'll still look green
and it'll even bloom with flowers if you
select the red plants
starting in march you can increase your
watering
to three days a week those three days a
week
can be eased into you don't have to go
out and change it all at one time on
march first
instead wait until the weather tells you
it's time to change
when it gets hot when we get up into the
70s then you can go out there and slowly
increase your watering from one day to
two days
and then add that third day in the weeks
ahead
to learn more call the southern nevada
water water authority at 702-822-8543 or
visit
snwa.com and don't forget the
snwa's water smart landscapes rebate
program
provides cash incentives of three
dollars per square foot
for residents residences and businesses
to ditch grass
and upgrade to drip irrigated trees and
plants
las vegas now we'll be right back